sur les murs de l'appartement de jean
luc partout des photos et des dessins de
sa fille qui lui manque tant
c'est normal parce que ça remplit guide
talent est pas là mais aujourd'hui
romane est là aujourd lakers pictures
romane qu'il ne voit qu'un week-end sur
deux et qui habite à une heure de route
il voudrait s'en rapprocher mais il n'en
a pas les moyens pourtant idéalement
vivre dans la navy lui permettrait de
mieux s'en occuper les dimanches soirs
nous les gars comme lundi matin je la
mets à l'école comme halo centre aéré le
mercredi et binche apprend on mercredi
et pourquoi pas du mardi soir ou jeudi
matin m la défense de mercredi moi j'ai
la chance de pouvoir avoir mon mercredi
ok bah c'est la france et le mois
prochain à terme jean luc souhaiterait
une garde alternée une semaine sur deux
comme 10% des coûts se séparer beaucoup
de faire la réclame certains ont
manifesté aujourd'hui déjà la loi leur
donne de nouveaux droits la loi donne la
possibilité aux magistrats de consacrer
le principe de la garde alternée la
résidence alternée
même en cas de désaccord de pavant ce
n'est plus un problème entre parents
c'est le problème de l'intérêt de
l'enfant alors le problème d'alliance et
de faire en sorte que la justice suive
le juge ne sont pas évidemment
trois sont si dès qu'il ya le moindre
conflit on donne les enfants la mer et
ensuite on voit pour donner des petits
droit de visite en impression en fait en
mêlée les bear un peu comme dans the row
les entendre déboires de temps en temps
parce qu'un enfant s'élève à 2 même
séparément les pères réclame une vraie
parité
aujourd'hui en france deux millions
d'enfants vivent seules avec leur maman
pour beaucoup d'hommes demain la fête
des pères aura un goût amer